Voici le Démolisseur !
Surveille Jack-Jack !
- Mais je pensais que nous -
- Tu as entendu ta mère !
Sers-moi de trampoline !
On se retrouve en -
Être un super-héros est illégal.
Nous voulons combattre des méchants !
Ca me définit.
Nous ne disons pas que tu...
- Quoi ?
- Quelqu'un à la télé l'a dit.
EN JUIN
J'ai été approché par cet homme d'affaires.
Il veut parler de trucs de héros.
Aidez-moi à ramener les héros dans la lumière.
Nous avons besoin d'Elastigirl !
Au revoir, chéri !
Je surveille les enfants. Pas de soucis.
ILS SONT DE RETOUR.
Ce n'est pas comme ça...
... que tu dois le faire, papa.
Ils veulent qu'on le fasse comme ça.
Je ne connais pas cette manière.
Pourquoi changeraient-ils les maths ?
- Les maths sont les maths !
- C'est pas grave, papa !
Les maths sont les maths !
Dans le pays des rêves,
les rêves rêvent.
Leurs paupières si lourdes, elles tombent et...
se ferment.
DE DISNEY ET PIXAR
Je n'aurais pas pu le faire...
... si tu n'avais pas aussi bien pris la relève.
Je dois réussir.
Pour qu'elle puisse réussir.
C'est Elastigirl !
Pour que nous puissions réussir.
J'ai compris, Bob.
Qu'est-ce... ?
Ça, c'est bizarre !
Mais je ne peux pas continuer...
...à lui donner des cookies.
Il est bizarre !
- On ne mord pas Papa !
- Quoi !
LES INDESTRUCTIBLES 2
Fait correctement, le rôle de parent...
... est un acte héroïque.
Fait correctement.